c'était la deuxième fois que la défense
de frédéric péché demandait la levée de
sa mise en examen
c'est donc la deuxième fois que la
chambre de l'instruction rejette en
appel cette demande
frédéric péchenard est donc soupçonné
est poursuivi pour cet empoisonnement
volontaire dont deux cas mortels
à l'époque il exerçait dans deux
cliniques privées de besançon malgré
cette nouvelle décision défavorable la
défense reste optimiste je vous propose
d'écouter l'un des avocats de frédéric
péché ornella spatafora pour l'instant
la chambre de l'instruction
malheureusement reste très prudent dans
ce dossier bien trop à notre goût
on espère pour autant on ne change pas
notre fusil d'épaulé en disant que
réellement ce dossier plus il avance
finalement et plus on est serein c'est à
dire c'est à dire qu'on considère que
jusqu'à présent on n'a absolument pas
apporté la preuve ou l'existence
d'indicés graves ou concordants qui
permettent de mettre en cause le docteur
pêcher dans ce dossier est reine pour
les avocats de frédéric peschier
l'enquète a été menée à charge et
uniquement à charge la suite du dossier
maintenant ce sont de nouvelles
expertises scientifiques il y en a
énormément dans cette affaire très
technique
ensuite la justice devra déterminer s'il
ya lieu d'organiser ou non un procès